[Música]
y para toda la actualidad económica del
mundo nos acompaña nuestro periodista
Jorge Hurtado Jorge buen martes para
ustedes y bienvenido Igualmente María
Clara bueno comenzamos en Estados Unidos
donde hay una noticia positiva porque la
inflación se moderó levemente bueno la
inflación general anual disminuyó al
nivel más bajo desde abril del 2021 el
índice de precios al consumo aumentó en
Estados Unidos en mayo un 0,1% en su
tasa intermensual y un 4% en los últimos
12 meses aunque los datos muestran que
no todo va por buen camino la inflación
subyacente que es este dato que excluye
los precios de los alimentos y la
energía aumentó un 0,4% en mayo
intermensual y un 5,3% anual a lo largo
Pues de los últimos meses la inflación
subyacente se ha convertido en un
indicador indispensable para el estudio
del comportamiento real de los precios
así como una referencia para las
decisiones de los bancos centrales y los
analistas el precio de la vivienda junto
con vehículos y usados fue el que más
presionó a este aumento mensual de todos
los artículos mientras que comer fuera
de casa aumentó en mayo en Estados
Unidos un cero coma dos por ciento tras
permanecer Intocable por los últimos dos
meses la energía también bajo un
3,6%. estos datos ahora brindan un nuevo
margen a la reserva Federal que es el
Banco Central de Estados Unidos para
tomarse un respiro en la subida de los
tipos de interés durante esta semana que
es lo que justo espera en la mayoría de
los inversores el informe se publicó
cuando los responsables de la reserva
Federal comienzan su reunión de dos días
sobre el futuro de la política monetaria
la reserva Federal lleva 10 subidas
consecutivas del precio del dinero y
esto marcará la semana en la bolsa de
hecho ya el índice esmp500 entró
oficialmente en territorio alcista desde
la semana pasada y se recupera de una
racha bajista la más prolongada que tuvo
desde 1948 ya usted nos da una breve
introducción pero continuemos explicando
en este contexto cómo se portaron Los
indicadores Este martes bueno
rápidamente empecemos que fue un buen
día y para la bolsa de Estados Unidos él
es en p500 y el nasdaq aglutina las
tecnológicas alcanzaron nuevos máximos
de un año tras el dato de inflación en
Europa el índice stock 600 cerró con una
subida del 0,55% mientras que la bolsa
de Sao Paulo en América Latina cerró con
una caída del 0,51% Pero bueno en
Estados Unidos lastimosamente no todas
las noticias son positivas porque tras
el colapso de un tramo de la carretera
Interestatal 95 esto en el noreste de
Filadelfia Se podrían cambiar los
precios esto lo dijo el secretario de
transportes de Estados Unidos pitbully
es que afirmó que podría haber un
aumento de precios en la costa este la
Interestatal va de Miami a la frontera
entre Main y Canadá la carretera se
parte de una ruta crítica para el
transporte de larga distancia el tramo
de esta autopista que se derrumbó el
domingo tras el incendio de un camión
cisterna transporta a una media de
160.000 vehículos al día el 8% de todos
estos vehículos son camiones comerciales
según el funcionario por esa carretera
circula diario gran parte del producto
interno bruto de Estados Unidos y según
la asociación estadounidense de camiones
ahora los camiones de carga tendrán que
dar una vuelta aproximada de 65 km de
carretera que no son interestatales y
que incluyen más de 60 semáforos esto
generaría un mayor impacto en la
economía estadounidense y pasamos a
América Latina porque la gira de Wonder
la ley en está dando buenas noticias y
es que se estima que el acuerdo mercosur
Unión Europea por fin podría comenzar
este año Así lo dijo control Legend
durante su visita en Argentina y si se
aprueba este acuerdo es importante
mencionar que vincularía dos mercados
que suman una población de 800 millones
de personas y que en conjunto
representarían una cuarta parte del
producto interno bruto mundial
básicamente el acuerdo reduciría Los
aranceles aduaneros y facilitaría el
acceso de los exportadores agropecuarios
sudamericanos hacia Europa así como el
de los fabricantes europeos a los países
del mercosur escuchamos parte de la
intervención de Úrsula wonderline
espero que podamos conseguir que el
acuerdo mercosur Unión Europea cruce la
línea de meta hemos intercambiado una
primera carta estamos esperando una
respuesta y tenemos muchas ganas de
trabajar al máximo para que concluyamos
este acuerdo como un acuerdo beneficioso
para todos lo antes posible
y antes de llegar a Argentina estuvo en
Brasil y Precisamente hay una noticia
económica en el gigante sudamericano
porque la empresa minorista americanas
admitió fraude por primera vez bueno la
empresa admitió inconsistencias
contables que rondan los 4.000 millones
de dólares según ellos es el resultado
de fraude cometido por una anterior
administración y acusaron a siete
ejecutivos entre ellas el exilio Miguel
Gutiérrez americanas dijo que los
informes financieros habían sido
falseados según un comunicado para
continuar las operaciones de la empresa
los ejecutivos contrajeron una serie de
deudas a nombre de la empresa con
excusas de financiación Y aunque no
menciona algún tipo de rendición de
cuentas de parte de los tres socios
principales tras este escándalo contable
la empresa solicitó un plan de
reorganización
o de auxilio financiero que aún está en
negociaciones ya veremos Entonces qué
pasa Jorge Gracias por las noticias
económicas nos vemos aquí en la próxima
nos vemos dentro de poco y ustedes sigan
conectados en France 24 hacemos una
breve pausa y en minutos regresamos con
la intervención de Donald Trump desde
Nueva Jersey
[Música]